marek I just want to find my friend I
need you to do a favor for me first you
mess around I'll kill you both so tell
me about Miss Bala why do you want to do
it what should audience expect from this
film well for me I want to do it because
I saw the original and working with
Catherine Hardwicke and Gina Rodriguez
was something that I felt can only be a
good situation for me I felt like the
three of us could do something really
unique and fun and people would enjoy to
see it the original movie was so good I
felt like Catherine could do something
really funny unique with it so when I
saw it I signed everything tell me about
this film what do you think audiences
should expect from it when it comes out
I think audiences should expect from
Isabela a story of empowerment and wit
with a female lead woman that goes from
ordinary to extraordinary using
everything at her disposal you know and
defying every are against people who may
have questionable desires but again also
from even from the characters that you
could say are bad guys you can also see
that it's not a stock that's simple it's
a complicated world and you will see
complicated characters that you might
find yourself even rooting for
you